marina trump pretende pretende acercarse
a estos legisladores estatales para
lograr que no se certifique en los votos
electorales los votos el voto popular
que no se certifique allá en michigan un
voto como usted lo mencionaba supera los
150 mil votos en ese estado al no lograr
certificar estos votos demorando este
proceso con demandas y con presión y con
este tipo de reuniones esto obligaría
entonces a precisamente estos
legisladores estatales a tener que pues
nombrar nuevos delegados electorales
teniendo en cuenta que en estados como
michigan como elevada como arizona los
legisladores son de mayoría republicana
pues entonces los delegados electorales
que elegirían serían también
republicanos delegados electorales que
terminarían entonces cambiando la
voluntad del voto popular y pues
terminarían depositando después del 14
de diciembre cuando los delegados
electorales que inició el pueblo no
pueden votar estos nuevos delegados
electorales entonces sí no
y lo hagan entonces por donald trump
entre los que están invitados y los que
están en la casa blanca se reunieron ya
con el presidente trump están michael
key que es el líder de la mayoría
republicana en el senado estatal de
michigan y también está richard field
que es el presidente de la cámara de
representantes ellos han dicho que
todavía no saben exactamente para qué
fueron convocados pero pues obviamente
los medios locales están diciendo que es
para ejercer esa presión y lograr pues
ese cambio de delegados electorales se
necesitan como bien mencionaba usted del
colegio electoral que se reúne el 14 de
diciembre es quien finalmente decide
quién es el ganador de las elecciones de
eeuu hay posibilidades de que éste
cambie los resultados actuales que dan
por ganador a joe biden
pues los mismos litchfield y mike que
están aquí reunidos han dicho que el
objetivo de ellos no es cambiar a los
delegados electorales ni es pues nombrar
nuevos delegados electorales
independientemente de la voluntad del
presidente ellos quieren seguir pues
firmes a lo que dijo el pueblo lo que
dijo la población en michigan además
pues le han dicho associated press que
ellos legalmente tampoco tienen la
potestad de precisamente nombrar nuevos
delegados electorales por más presión
que ejerza el presidente de hecho el
gobernador del estado de michigan que
ese demócrata ha dicho que
independientemente de todas las
reuniones que quiera hacer el presidente
en la casa blanca no se va a poder
cambiar el rumbo de la voluntad popular
de los más de 155 mil ciudadanos en
música que votaron por el candidato
demócrata joe by bien además pues lo que
dice el gobernador es que esta elección
fue limpia que no hay pruebas de fraude
y pues que esto
el presidente de trump pues se confirmen
los resultados allá en michigan y tenga
que aceptar el resultado sin embargo
marina hay que mencionar que la
constitución no obliga a estos delegados
electorales que fueron elegidos por el
pueblo a tener que votar por el
candidato que le sugirió pues el voto
popular